if you haven't watched who we play for
we put a face up there and Chuck ass
patellas who we plays W go this is a
waste of time let's go with player
number one it's Garrett temple what's
not Chuckster Garrett temple who he
played for the Detroit Pistons
what did you say underdog fifth straight
year we've had Garrett yeah well you
didn't I'm so euro for Watson please I
have absolutely no faith in you on this
one Solomon Hill who he played for don't
look at the glassing teams just the Utah
Jazz
oh he just sees Utah he's Memphis
Grizzlies your old friend that his
jersey it was blue non-stop this one's
almost a layup Kenny I think no it is it
Noah Vonleh
who he played for the Minnesota
Timberwolves 0 for 3 different ones Co
ha ha okay who CJ Miles play fortunately
the Indiana paint so that was two years
ago Washington Wizards you were right
here's this guy I don't know how many
times anthony tollivers been on here but
he's contestant number five Oklahoma
City
Oh what did you say in the guy before
Portland yes yeah well he plays for
Portland that's an O for five that is
just utterly disappointing but we do
have one more chance for it it must give
them like a star well we have one more
chance for you like this is a guy are
you all stop remember you've you've had
this guy on who we play for many many
times
Haley kind of and so we Coatesville and
so we've got this video from him you see
let's go roll the video I know you
couldn't remember what teams are playing
for
let's try this one more time hey Chuck
who our coach for that's crazy
Willie green big Clippers where do you
live that's funny I don't even though we
gonna do that with great minds take a
light upstairs
I love will agree I didn't know he
coached for the Sun it was my son KJ
favorite player boys because he won't go
mad oh I haven't even chance to scout
these guys out scout you just watch a
game yeah watch boy you know watch some
games look at some box scores you even
know what Willie Percy will coach for
any and you live in Phoenix he got a
house next to yours he said he can't
afford my neighbors good no he doing